don't frighten the north-south fight
every battle everywhere always in your
mind
you
[Music]
the centuries our families brought
together against their common enemy
despite their differences together
we need to do the same if we conspired
the enemy is real
it's always been real
[Music]
the snow is full and the light winds
blow the lone wolf dies but the packs
vote
[Music]
you
you
hey guys Pete here and there was the new
trailer the winner is here version and
man I've been hyped up for like the last
five hours since that thing came out all
right so I'm going to break it down
scene by scene I'm gonna do it spoiler
free and then I'm only going to talk
about what we see not what we learned
before this evening
so please be respectful in the comments
here anybody that's followed my stuff
and all the other stuff out there knows
what a lot of this is but don't ruin it
for other people who are just avoiding
spoilers nobody cares if you know
exactly what I'm talking around whatever
I'm avoiding saying something here there
so don't float it out in the comments
and ruin it I would definitely do a
spoiler related version of this if
you're interested you can comment that
but for this one let's just make it fun
for everybody so we start off with
Santa's she's walking back from the
weirwood at Winterfell
this could be exactly after we saw her
there in season 6 or it could be at a
different time we hear a voice over and
it's Littlefinger and he says don't
fight in the north or the south by every
battle everywhere in your mind then we
see a shot of the gate at the wall
opening which we've seen in previous
trailers but this time we get the big
payoff I've been waiting for for a long
time my man bran stark and mayor Reid
have arrived of course we know John is
probably not there but this stark has
gone beyond the wall way to the north
has made his way back and he's one step
closer to home after that we see a shot
of the king in the north himself swing
around
he has skins on and the background
definitely looks like Iceland which
means he's probably north of the wall I
can't make out who the hooded character
behind him is so let me know if you guys
figured out who that was we'll get an
outside shot of King's Landing followed
by a shot of Queen Cersei inside she
kind of does a half turn like Jon did in
the previous clip and I noticed after
watching the whole thing
this is about all the Cersei we get so
we'll get another trailer later that it
revolves some more around her although
the first one did in the perennial so
whatever Daenerys is indoors at
Dragonstone and we see the shot of her
dragging her hand across the map table
that we caught a glimpse of in the HBO
Spain trailer the quick flash of the
beach landing or possibly someone
pushing off it's hard to make out who
this is even when you lighten it and
zoom in it looks like it could be a
couple of things that we saw during
filming but I don't want to speculate
any further than that
we do see something later with the yarn
that might be related to this but I'm
really not sure next we see Aria on
horseback which looks like the same bit
from the really short clips that we got
from HBO way back when she's riding up
and is looking towards something we
don't really know what it is but she has
a look on her face for sure and it could
very well be Winterfell although there's
nothing to say that that is the case we
see Jaime walking along on the top of a
castle wall there's a dead body as he
rounds the corner and when we see the
higher wall in front of him it seems
pretty obvious that he's in a different
location than the castle that was in the
HBO Spain trailer and that trailer we
saw the Lannister troops clashing with
the unsullied
but the Lannisters were in a defensive
position the banners indicated that was
most likely Casterly Rock and the walls
there were smooth looking we also didn't
see Jaime there at all and he would
generally be in King's Landing with
Cersei anyway so here he is on what
looks like the offensive inside a castle
we haven't seen in any other seasons or
at least it doesn't look familiar to me
since I already know where he is for the
most part I'm not going to say but and I
don't want to spoil it for anyone else
I'll just leave it at that
let me see Littlefinger creeping again
sort of hiding in a little space there
like a little weasel I realized that
this shot is kind of annoying to me
we've seen it a couple times and where
is it could this be what led to what
looked like a choking from Jon Snow in
the first
learn I don't know I mean it's
mysterious it should be at Winterfell
but it's just one of those kind of shots
where it doesn't give you anything to
work with
it's little finger being little finger
and yeah we see a quick shot of some
we're sharpening a blade not much to go
off information wise there and then we
see Daenerys walking alone on the beach
by dragon stone and we get a shot of a
cave and the second voice-over starts I
alluded to this in my breakdown for the
Spain trailer she was in a cavernous
looking space with the torch that could
be related to this anyways the
voice-over this time is John Snow and he
says for centuries our families fought
together against their common enemy
while he's talking we see Daenerys come
across one of Stannis's banners which
she pulls down then we get our first
dragon shot of all you know it's all
three of them flying towards the castle
John continues despite their differences
together we need to do the same if we're
going to survive because the enemy is
real we get a sequence of shots of the
Targaryen faithful we see tearing and
looking grave on the cliffs outside
Dragonstone beyond in the dark near
flames on the deck of a ship and grey
worm on a small boat approaching a rocky
shoreline after that we see Brienne and
pod in the yard at Winterfell then we
cut to a shot of the Hound in the heat
of a fight the cut is really quick here
but he looks bundled up with snow-capped
mountains behind him the very next scene
is an unsullied
hitting the ground in a completely
different location we can see that he's
been hit by an arrow and the field
around him is littered with them we saw
archers in the HBO spaying trailer and
we see them later here but this is
probably not the same scene as that this
is probably at Casterly Rock as well
after that we get this incredible
looking Dothraki charged in two waiting
shields and Spears you can clearly make
out Lions on the wooden shields but I
guess that isn't a big surprise go back
to the beginning and watch that that's
like little extra
change in full speed again after this is
over and just think about filming that
like they're running horses full speed
into waiting shields not to be outdone
by the ground battle we get this
crazy-looking shot of the battle at sea
with what looks like Yarra jumping off
the top deck then we see the shot that I
was just talking about of the Lannister
archers and we can see that was Jamie
behind them in the last trailer and that
he's also got Bronn at his side and some
serious backup and equipment behind that
it looks like they're moving along the
road and taking up a defensive position
people who followed spoilers with me
last year know exactly what's happening
here but I am NOT going to get into that
then we get a sequence I totally missed
on the first watch it's a flock of
Ravens so the lamb is what looks like a
gang of white but you can't really tell
for sure and then it cuts straight to
the night king so all of this might
actually be intertwined but you can't
really say for sure since things are
generally jumbled up in the trailers
either way we go from the night king
straight to brand who has his eyes
rolled back in his head and full skin
change mode and here's another twist on
that I was looking at Twitter while I
was making this and I saw that history
of Westeros posted that the eye of the
Raven switches from black to blue and I
noticed there was a little bit of a
flash there and I thought it was just
bran controlling the Raven like it was
there so that we could tell that bran
was controlling it but with the blue
that makes it seem like it might be a
battle in the bird's mind between the
night King and bran and like I said I
didn't I didn't notice that at all I saw
the history of Westeros posted that on
Twitter but that's an interesting
thought at the very least then it cuts
to him in a wheelchair by a weirwood
tree that sure does look like the one at
Winterfell so yeah he's got a chair
there appears to be someone looking
after him which we know maesters do that
sort of thing in this system that they
got going there and this shot we see
what looks like a maester from behind
and this maester looks like it could
definitely be the one who was
at Winterfell with the Bolton's maester
wolkan now you might think well why
would they be with them you know the
maesters aren't they don't belong to any
house they just take care of the people
who live in the house does that make
sense so even though he was the Meister
when the Bolton's were there when the
Bolton's are gone he would still be the
Meister when the Starks we took over or
whatever so I'm gonna say this is brand
net winter faux this is Brandon stark
sitting by the weirwood tree at
Winterfell
or it could just be Brandon some guy
standing by a tree somewhere else here
John's voice again say it's always been
real
and then we see beric Dondarrion with a
sword that bursts into flame I guess
this is a trick like we've seen in the
past so don't get all essaouira high
crazy here but it looks cool too and
really complement the heavy furs he's
wearing for something that looks like a
trip north of the wall after that we get
a shot of the Greyjoy fleet approaching
King's Landing I would assume that this
is the replacement Greyjoy fleet that
you're on though after his niece and
nephew took the ones that were there
he's rolling into the capital most off
you know most likely to offer services
there for a price we don't see his crows
I fiddle but at the same time at the end
of season six when we saw the Maris's
fleet they weren't flying Greyjoy sails
you know they were all basically flying
the Targaryen sails after that there's a
few shots of the Targaryen unsullied
in the sequence we see them in formation
we see them opening the gate and what
looks like Casterly Rock from the
Spanish trailer there's a very
interesting shot that's quick of
Daenerys it's sort of slipped in there
she's outside of Dragonstone it looks
like she's receiving someone she turned
slightly and it seems like it might be a
really important meeting when we see
this again as the whole scene after that
Jaime's riding his white horse in the
aftermath of what appears to be the very
same battle where we saw him in bra
in the archers certainly not clear who
had the upper hand here but it's obvious
an insane amount of carnage went down we
get a straight shot on of Jamie who is
having well he's hauling ass is what
he's doing he's got a very determined
look on his face while he does it then
we see a massive explosion on the deck
of a ship and can you believe we are
just 1 minute and 15 seconds into this
trailer at this point tornados fighting
for his life but who he is fighting
against isn't exactly clear this appears
to be related to John and Barrack but we
only see as opponent is wearing black is
it a white or is it a white of a fallen
night's watch brother I honestly don't
know even though I followed all the
spoilers because if this is what I think
it is there are really no photos of
other cast members at this location
premiere we see Dothraki doing what
Dothraki do charging on horseback but
this time they have dragon air support
along with them if we think about all
the fire jamie was just sort of
surrounded by and sort of hauling ass
away from I think there's a real chance
that those two things could be connected
after that we see Fiona and Yara side by
side at night looking up it I think it's
safe to say that the look on your face
is one of great concern and it looks
like something flaming might be headed
their way to back this up we see a
fireball crash into a ship's sails in
the very next scene then we see
Lannister soldiers setting a line behind
their shields with spearmen behind them
again we see John on a disguise on top
of this rock outcropping sort of thing
and for some reason he looks like kind
of casual up there he might be stunned
or he might be overwhelmed but the whole
thing looks confusing to me the bodies
below seem to be advancing in his
direction and if I didn't know better I
would say it looks like they're about to
overwhelm and erase him from existence
but it's just a quick shot so it's not I
don't know I could be reading into it
too
much there's a little fast shot of Miss
Andy giving grey worm a full-blown
full-on mouth kiss and then another
quick look at Tyrion pondering something
on the countryside things get a little
tricky here we get some warmer weather
shots the first looks like King's
Landing at the dragon pit site it looks
like the helm drawing his sword but it
also looks like he is wearing no pants
or maybe uh shorts or skirt I don't know
it's weird he's probably got like
light-colored pants and it's just the
way the Sun is but it's really out of
place in relation to all the other stuff
that we're seeing where people are
wrapped up to be in the snow then
another little sneaky one may squeezed
in there it's a shot of John and Davos
where they're definitely not in the
north
John's wearing his king gear with Davos
by his side but that's really all that
we get then we see John in the very far
north fighting one of the white walkers
not away not the night king himself but
one of his main homies like you know you
know what I'm talking about after that
we see Dothraki rider straight up riding
through flames like what is going on
here I'm not really sure there I don't
think they're on fire I think they're
just crashing through but it's a pretty
intense looking scene then we see what
looks like beyond to me on shore
Dragonstone dropping to his knees it
could be somebody else it looks like
Deon though with this haircut he only
has a small landing craft that we can
see in the picture and then we see his
evil ass uncle you're on smashing
someone in a one-on-one battle smashing
them to death and then it cuts to drag
on who is checking someone out at
Dragonstone we could see the castle
behind him and he's looking at something
he looks curious more than I'm gonna you
know something like I'm gonna catch you
on fire or eat you but how can you
really tell with the dragon here's a
look that big at first and then you look
and you kind of see that Daenerys is on
his back and she looks really small from
there we go way back up north and see
the boys circling up in the snow again
and just when you think why are they
doing this
again we saw this already it goes to
white out like it they disappear in the
snow and we hear a new voiceover from
salsa she says when the snows fall and
the white winds blow the lone wolf dies
but the pack survives and with that they
could have really have just ended it
right there but it doesn't do that at
all as she's saying it we did see that
it looks like dawn like a slumped over
injured Jon Snow escaping on horseback
you can't really tell for sure it could
be any of the people that were wrapped
in furs but hey you know my my guess
would have been John since he's the
important guy and then when she's
finished talking we see a fully upright
Jon Snow
hacking an adversary down with long
claws and this must be earlier obviously
if that was him on the horse because he
looks like he's just taking care of
business
notice the plier and the snowy
background here and just think about
that for a moment everything else we've
seen has been deadly ice cold everywhere
and then here there's some people
standing around not really clear whose
side they're on
but above them there's quite a bit of
fire and that had to come from somewhere
and then think about how John looks
they're flexing him after he kills that
guy as the trailer ends so yeah this was
awesome I haven't been so hyped up for
Game of Thrones as I was at this time
last year it's really a lot going on
it's already a long video that I have
going here and all I did was talk about
the scenes without any real speculation
as mentioned this one seems to it seems
to blend just about everything but there
are some key people that we don't see
much other anyways and then you know I
was thinking about it while I was
watching with only 7 episodes I think we
got a bit of probably most of them in
here we saw three separate battles we
saw an image of John where he looks like
he's far from the north and we saw
images of him where it looks like he's
way up above the wall in the north
biggest moment was for me was first
seeing Brandon mirror outside
of the wall and then that was quickly
outdone by him sitting in the chair by
the weirwood in Winterfell yeah that's
just think about it think about how long
ago in the story he took off and now I
mean he had a whole season where he
wasn't even in it he was just under the
tree like we didn't see him and now he's
back at home and those Ravens were
obviously had something to do with him
which I like that quite a bit all the
battle stuff looks insane I don't think
anybody's gonna get bored watching these
episodes you know there's been a lot of
talk about urine I made it your own
video earlier is like hardly anyone
watched it there was not much interest I
guess but there's not a lot of these
articles going around about how he's
gonna be so crazy I don't understand how
his storyline really fits into doing
much I mean obviously we saw him on the
deck killing somebody and that appears
to be in a battle with Yara and Theon on
the other side and then we see the ships
coming up to King's Landing but where is
he got all this time to be crazy I guess
on his ship as they're going I don't
know but um yeah I'm hide I'm gonna quit
rambling at this point because the video
is too long already leave any questions
you have in the comments please like the
video if you enjoyed it I try to answer
if you got specific spoilery stuff ask
me and I will paste the link in for one
of the spoiler videos that it talks
about that like I said please don't ruin
it for everybody there's a time and
place for everything and this is just a
place to enjoy how awesome that trailer
was after this long long wait that we've
had
alright guys please subscribe thanks for
watching I'll talk to you soon